それで私を分解するんですね
自分というもの 五蘊 まあ五体と言ってもいいんですの
私 私は五体でできているんだというと
なんか手足やと思っちゃいますけど
その五体じゃないんです
その蘊という これはパーリ語でカンダと言うんですね
とは似ているタイプ 同類のものを集められた塊という意味です
まあ車でも分解すると
金属 プラスチックのもの
ゴムのものとか 分解できるんですよ
その人の考え方によって
例えば電気に関わるもの
機械に関わるものとかね
分解できます  例えばドイツなんかではもうほとんど車はまあ分解して処分するんだから
微妙に分解するんですね
金属は金属で 金属の中でもリサイクルできるもの
できないもの プラスチックものは別々に
それでリサイクルできるもの
できないもの それから鉄の部分とかね
それから液体は別に ガソリンやらオイルやら別に
そうやってもうきめ細かく分解するんです
分解する塊に 山にするんですね
山にして再利用する そう
ドイツで車分解したら結構山いくつか見つかるんですね
最後に そういう風に自分を分解すれば
お釈迦様も山 5つを見つけたんです 5
つに分けたんです はい
同類であっても同質ではありません
それも覚えてほしいんです
リセッブルバットノットアイデンティカルということで
まあ英語で言えば同じことですけど
うんという言葉にもう体体系
カテゴリーという言葉も使っても構いません
パーリ語でカーヤという言葉も使います
うんと言えばカンダですけど
まあカーヤという言葉も使ってます
人の執着はこの五蘊に対するものなので
なんとか五取蘊ウパーダーナカンダという言葉も使っています
我々はこの 5つの塊に執着しているんです
だからウパーダーナカンダ
パンチウパーダーナカンダと言うんですね
それで 1番目 もう5つありますよ
1番目 ルーパウパーダーナカンダ
これからちょっと丁寧に勉強しないと
で ルーパ なんか文章を一つ抜けてるみたいです
ルーパと言えば体のこと
で 体のことなんで これ大中に柱になっているのは地水火風というものなんですね
で パーリ語でパタウィ
アーポー テジョー ワーヨーと言うんです
この 5つの塊で 1番目はルーパと呼ぶんです
ルーパっていうのはこの肉体のこと
自分の体のまあ 入りました
ルーパウパーダーナカンダ
ルーパカンダとも言います
それでもう日本語で色と言うんですけど
体 物質的体系 物質の塊という意味なんです
まず我々には体があるんです
体っていうのはただの物質
で 下書いてるものは 生命の体というと
物質的な世界 宇宙が構成されているもの
それで物質といえば もう建物も物質で
地球も物質で 宇宙も物質なんです
私の体は物質なんです
皆様の体は物質なんです
ものなんです それに仏教でルーパという言葉を使うんです
ルーパには間違って色という漢字をつけて使ってるんですよ
で これはもう大変な間違いなんです
なぜかというと ルーパという言葉を辞書を引くと
普通のサンスクリット語
あるいは他のインド語の辞書を引いて引いてみると
まあもう形とかね まあまあ
絵とかね その時使う言葉なんです
しかし その意味でお釈迦様は使ったんじゃないんです
物質という意味で使ったんです
でもう明らかに物質という言葉でそういうことを説明して使っているし
で それで定義しなくちゃあかんだから
このまあ物質っていうのはすぐ壊れるんだと
壊れるんだからルーパと言うんであって
もう形があるんだから綺麗だからルーパと言うんじゃないよと
もうちゃんと定義しています
ルッパティーティルーパン
ルッパのラックナーティルーパンという風に
この注釈書などで定義しているんです
これが読んでないんですね
翻訳するときは だから色という
漢字入れてしまったんです
これで困ることに後でなっちゃいますけどね
では 私たちを私を分解すると
第一に発見するのはこの肉体という体なんです
これが何の不思議もない
世の中全部同じものでできている
今の体でもこの世の地球からもらったものなんですよ
お腹の中で精子卵子合体して自分が生まれますけど
精子卵子っていうのはもうもう体から出るものだから
それはただ地球のものなんです
そこにまた地球のものを入れて
入れて入れて入れて入れて大きくするだけ
だから体に対して私は私はと思ったっても
何のこともない土そのものなんです
地球の物質なんです 地球でない物質は一つもこの体の中でないんですよ
まあ主に体にあるのはあれ
カーボンでしょうし 硬いものといえば
カーボンって何でしたっけ？炭素
炭素 それからまあ水でしょうし
まあ九十五パーセント以上あるのは
まだいくつか もうほんのわずかわずか
もうナトリウムやらカリウムやらもういろいろあります
フォスファラスとかいろいろ
カルシウムとかね そんなもういくつかの品物でできている
地球のものなんですよ
と面白いことに で ご飯食べていろんなものをして体を大きくするんだけど
全部物質なんですね だから色と物質といえば
自分の体も外の世界も宇宙も
なんだかんだでも同じものでできているんだと
ということを理解してほしい
はい それから説明に行きます
体の説明に行きます はい
そこでこの物質といっても大きい柱になっているのは４つ
例えば皆様 学校でもう百以上の元素あると聞いたことあると思いますけど
仏教は４つだというんですね
そんなたくさんないんだと
その４つにもすごい俗っぽい単語を使うんです
難しい単語を使っちゃうと
もうもうむちゃくちゃになるんです
それはもう 科学者ですってね
わけもわからない単語を作るんですね
それもふざけていい加減なんですけど
わけもわからない それで一般人がなるほど難しいんだ
全然難しくないんです
もう科学ほど簡単な学問はないんですよ
で 一番難しい学問というのは仏教学なんですけど
でお釈迦様はなんのことなく地水火風という誰でも知ってる単語使ってます
それでパーリ語でパテリヤーポーテージョワーヨと言うんです
そこでパテリって何なのかというと
硬さも簡単単純で覚えてください
硬さ 重さ 質量を司る機能
パテリというんです どんなものにも硬さがありますし
もう重さというものもあるし
まあ重さっていうのは難しい言葉で言えば質量なんですね
どんなものを見てもあるんですよ
何を見ても硬いでしょうね
そうすると空気はどうですかね
空気は結構硬いんですよ
硬いんだからこそ もう人間にできんことまでやっちゃいますからね
もう今はもうアメリカの方で竜巻はつなげていくでしょうね
もうもう全部もうもうもうぺっちゃんこにしているんです
人も結構死んじゃって
あれただの空気ですけど
すごい硬いんですよ 建物を倒す場合は
どれほど硬さぶつからないとできるものじゃないんですよ
だから空気も何だかんでも硬さがあるんです
それがもうパテリという元素ですね
元素じゃない機能です
ファンクションですね
はい 次はあっと固める
離れよう これまた間違い
離れないようにする 離れないようにする
引き寄せる機能はアーポーというんです
それで私たちはもう体を見ても
指を引いても引いてもなかなか離れてくれないんですね
人の子供のほっぺたでも引いちゃうと
一部取ってくるともう大変でしょうね
そう ほっぺた引いたっても
もう抜けてはくれないんです
お互いつなげているんです
この机なんか二人で両方に引っ張っても引っ張ってもなかなか割れてくれないんです
机は自分でじっと固めているんです
離れないように それでどんなものでも自分なりに固めているんです
それにアーポーと言うんです
水 水というんですね こう発見するのは簡単ですよ
例えばメリケン粉があるでしょ
あれにふーっと吹いたら
もうあっちこっち飛び散らしちゃうんですよ
それに水をかけて混ぜればどうなるんですかね
水を入れれば混ぜちゃうとたちまち固めるんです
さらにさらに混ぜると
引いても引いても粘り強く
もう なかなか離れない状態になるんです
だから そういう単純なことでもこの真理わかるんだから
そういう言葉を使うんです
どういうことかというと
メリケン粉で言えば あの地パテリの方がたくさんなります
それから風 風というものもたくさん入っています
だからバラバラなんです
それに水を入れちゃうと
風という風というものは出て行っちゃうんです
出て行っちゃうと 水のエネルギーが大きくなるんです
割合で それで離れなくなっちゃうんです
それでそれ 2番目ですね
3番目 定常 これ熱温度ということですね
また変化を引き起こす機能
定常です 何でも何で変化するのかというと
その中に熱というものがあるんですよ
この熱がものを変えちゃうんですよ
そのものを変化する機能に熱と言うんです
それどうやって発見するのかというと簡単でしょ？いろいろなものに熱を加えてみてください
たちまち変化する 何でもいいんです
熱を加えるとたちまち変化する
それでみんなそれ逆さまにとっているでしょうに
熱を加えないことにする
そうすると腐るんでしょ
食べ物は なんで冷蔵庫に食べ物を放り込むんですかね
熱を加えないようにするということでしょう
しかし ずっと熱が生まれるんですよ
だから冷蔵庫は 24時間機能しないとダメなんです
ずっと熱がもう頑張っているんです
だったら ずっとその余分余計な熱をもう取り出さなくちゃいけないんです
これで終わりがないんですね
今 液体窒素の中に入れて
いろんな人間の体の部品なんか保存しておくでしょうし
まあ今最近 まあ精子ぐらいでしょうしね
精子卵子とかね まあ液体窒素の液体窒素に入れると
もうなかなかもう熱はもう入らない
そこであの小さな入れ物に入れたものが
ものすごい大きなものに入れておくと
一人で頑張っても頑張っても熱出して熱出して
または精子バンクとかね
ありますからね それを小さな入れ物に入れて
液体窒素に入れておくんです
液体窒素を入れるものは結構大きいんですよ
それでも精子は頑張ってますよ
熱を出してやるぞと 出しても出しても全部吸い取られますから
一応変化は遅れる しかし
それでは使えないんですよ
ノーマルな状態でなければ
だから人間は だったら人間液体窒素で生きていられれば永遠でしょうに
ありえないんです もう人間じゃないんです
その時は だからこの精子も液体窒素の中にある場合は
精子としては仕事はしない
別なものになっています
そこはまた普通の温度になってくると
また回転始まるんです
ということは また変化始まるんです
それでいろいろ受精させたり
いろんなことができるようになるんです
変化するときは 次は何でしたっけ？あ
ワーヨ 大きさを決める
引き離す 動きの機能ですね
または動きの機能はワーヨ
頑張ってこの４つを理解してほしい
この４つを理解すると
全部物質わかったことになるんです
それ ４つで終わるんですよ
お釈迦様は徹底分析したおかげで
何でも簡単にわかるようになるんです
例えば何か物を持っちゃうと
例えば もう何かもう簡単なものないんですけど
もう何でもいいんで 例えばカップというものがあるんですね
これにも何か大きさがあるんですよ
この大きさ決めているのはわよというものなんです
かせというものなんです
なんでかせという漢字作っているのかというと
かせがあると膨らむんだからね
風船にかせ吹いちゃうとどうなるんですか？どんどん大きくなる
風船にかせ吹いたんだからといって
何か怒るわけじゃないんですよ
こちらのかせがそちらに入っただけの話で
でもそれでもそれであのゴムが大きいスペースを自分で取る
だから人間の体でもかせの元素が大きくなれば
ものすごい大きくなるんですね
でもすごい体がでっかい人はぶよんぶよんでしょうに
そこで風の方が減っていくと体が締まってくるんでしょうし
その時は体硬いんです
スポーツとかいろんなことをして
すごくスマートな体 筋肉だけの体を持ってる人の体というのは硬い
筋肉は それに風の働きが入っちゃうと
もうものすごく膨らませてぶよんぶよん状態になります
それでこのものはあるというと
この三次元の世界で何かスペースを取らなくちゃいけないんですね
それないとどこにあるのかわからなくなっちゃうんです
だからものの大きさ決める
それは風です ということは
どうやって大きさを決めるかというと
ある物質とある物質の間を作っておくんですよ
間がないと一緒になって一緒になって 1個になってしまうんです
大きくならない 水に水を入れると一緒になるような錯覚するでしょうに
一緒にならないんですよ
だから半分のガラスの水にもう半分入れちゃうといっぱいになってるんです
水は水と簡単に一緒になるんではない
そうならない 全然 他のものを足せば足すほどどんどん大きくなります
足しても足しても大きくならないというわけじゃないんです
では質問なんですけど
水に塩を溶かしたらどうなるんでしょうかと
大きくなるんですかね
その場合は風じゃないんです
重くなるんです あの地がバッテリーが増えるんです
しかし 大きくならないと
水に水に塩を溶いても溶いても多くならないというのは
それまた勘違いで 塩そのものを持ってるボリュームが入るんです
それはちょっとあまりも小さくて測れません
塩の結晶を見たら大きいんじゃないかな
結晶というのは中いっぱい風が入ってるんだから
本物の大きさじゃないんです
しかし 塩にも大きさがあるんです
その大きさの分は水が
水のボリュームが上がるんです
で 上がらないもう一つの理由っていうのは
水の中でいっぱい穴があるんですよ
ものすごい隙間があるんだから
その中に入り込むんですよ
それで隙間が全部終わっちゃうと
塩が溶けなくなっちゃうんです
それもボリュームが上がらない理由なんです
水の中に穴が隙間がなかったならば
ボリュームが上がっちゃうんです
例えば水の中に石を入れる
石を入れると石が水の中にある穴に入り込まないんです
水そのものを追い出しちゃうんで
出て行けと 私にこの場所必要やと
それでボリュームが上がっちゃうんです
そういうことで 小学校の授業みたいな
だから誰にでもわかると言ったんですよ
こんなのは 小学1年 2
年生の科学ぐらいのレベルでわかります
それでどんなものを取ってみても
例えばこのキャップを見る
これは何でできているのかというと
皆様はプラスチックではないかと
あれこれやと言うかもしれません
いろんな化学製品だと
仏教で言うのは いえ これは地水火風であると
地というのはこれ硬いでしょうに
だから触れるでしょうに
硬くなければ決して触ることはできないんです
それでこれ引いても引いても粉のようにサーッと出ていかないんですね
固めているんですね 硬いことと固めることは意味が違うんです
ちょっと英語の単語も書きたかったんですけど
こんな書けちゃうともうスライドにならないんですね
ボンドということ つなげている
ボンドトゥゲザー だからこれが硬いし
こうやって引いてもなかなかかなり力入れない限りはもう割れてくれないんですね
そうやってこうやって割れを割れをしても割れてくれないような
その仕事は この誰でしたっけ？アポという炭が水がやっているんです
そこでこちらにも温度があるんです
自分持ってるんです だからやがて変わる
やがてといってもずっと変わっていくんです
まあ我々は何でプラスチックのものを使ってますかというと
もう変化しないという錯覚なんです
でもプラスチックも変化する
ただ これには普通の紙の蓋とかね
あるいはコップの蓋なんかつけちゃうと
それも変化する しかし
それが随分早く変化する
これもゆっくりと変化していくんです
しかし 仏教の世界では変化に早いゆっくりはないんです
全部同じスピードで変化しているんです
ただ この現象になってくると違うだけ
米は一年 二年でも大丈夫です
変化はするんだけど まあ二年ぐらい経ってくると
まあ食べられなくなっちゃいます
私はもう四年 五年経ってる米も炊いて食べたことはありますけど
何のこともない 新米とは全くも変わりはないんです
みんな新米美味しいというのはおそらく舌が機能していないでしょう
で それほど変わりはない
しかし 年も持てる米をご飯という現象にすると別なものなんです
米じゃないんです それがもう一日
二日もう使えないんですね
だから現象になるとスピードは見えます
私はよく出す例は 大豆は軽々と一年
二年 三年持ちますよ 大豆潰して豆腐にするとせいぜい二日なんですね
しかし 質は同じ大豆なんです
でも豆腐は二日で食べられない状態になる
大豆だったらもう保存食として
もう何も加工物質を入れなくても置いておける
だから大豆という幻想で見ると
時間かかる変化するために
豆腐という現象はもう時間でもう変わってしまって
食べられない状態になる
まあ持ちたければ熱を加えないことなんですね
熱を働かせないようにと
まあ冷蔵保存するしかないんです
熱が働かないように それでこのカップを見ると
カップにも熱があるんだから
これがじわじわと変化していく
それから そのカップに大きさがありますね
その大きさは風という元素なんです
わよという元素なんです
だからどんなものにもあるのは地水火風であると
なんで地水火風にしたんですか？お釈迦様は
これすごい大事なポイントなんです
認識できるんですよ あるということは
100%の確率で知られます
でも科学者いう あれこれやとわからないんですよ
その人々も いろんな機械で数字を見たり計算したりしてあると言うんです
認識がないんです 経験できないんです
だから科学者はもう知らないものでもあると言い張ってるんだから
知らないというのは知られないものもあると言い張ってるんだから
複雑になっていて 仏教は認識できる範囲で語っているんです
だから認識できないものは
あるともないともどちらでも言えないものでしょうし
また 我々にとって何の関係もないでしょうし
そういうことで すべてのものは地水火風でできている
何でたくさんものがあるのかというと
この地水火風の割合が違うんです
この包丁を研ぐということをするんですね
よく上手に研いじゃうとよく切れるでしょ
切れるってどういう意味ですかね
研ぐっていうことは 包丁ができている
この木の部分をすごく細くするんです
歩を飛ばしちゃうんです
まあ例えば一個の鉄の
なんて言いますか 原子がある
それで間があってもう一個あると切れないんですよ
この太すぎて 鉄の原子があって
間があって間があって
こういう風に太くなっちゃうと
もう切れないんです そこで研いだ時にこちらに追っ払っちゃうんで出ていて
そうするといくつかの鉄の原子だけないんですね
そうするとどうなるかというと
この地の元素がよりたくさんになって
封の元素が逃げているんです
小さくなっているんです
小さいんだから切れるんです
で パンを切るとパンの間で風がありますね
その間で血が入るんです
入ったところでもうまた繋げなくなっちゃうんです
それで切ったということになるんです
しかし 水の中に包丁を持っていっても
持っていっても切れないんですよ
だって 水そのものがつなげるものだから
水そのものがつなげる機能していますから
水の場合はつなぎ機能がもの大量にあるんです
だから水の上でどんな鋭い包丁を持っていっても持っていっても水は切れません
そのようにこの地水火風の
割合によって様々なものが見えるだけ
まあそれだけで基本的な元素は終わります
またもうちょっと付け加えることがあります
四大元素と呼ぶんですね
その 4つね 互いに依存し
離れません 決して地だけは一人ではいられません
ありえないんです 水火風も一緒にいるんです
だから一番小さなユニットをとってみても
地水火風 4つの機能で最初のユニットができちゃうんですね
例えば素粒子といえば
素粒子そのものが地水火風の最初のユニットかもしれません
素粒子そのものが物か何物かと言えない状態なんです
しかし 素粒子ももう8種類ぐらい考えているんですけど
その中でどうやって区別するのかという
その機能で区別しているんですね
それでダブっているものがあるんだから
たくさんあるだけ 話難しくなるんだから
そこら辺はデータを持ってきてないんです
四大元素をよりどころにして
4つの色と言ったらまた困るんですよ 4
つの物質が現れますよ
で 次第 この四大元素 地水火風がまとめたところで
あら 不思議でまた 4つあるんです
四つの機能が見えてくるんです
この四つの機能は色 変わり
味 字音という四つなんです
だから原子一個にも色があるんですよ
あるんだからでしょ 遠い宇宙にあるいろんな原子でもあれでできてる
これできてる できてるのはスペクトラムで
酸素だったらこの色とかあるんです
だから色という独立したものがないんです
小さいカーフがどれぐらい組み合わせたっていうことによって色が決めるんです
例えば酸素の元素と炭素の元素といえば
小さいカーフが違うでしょ
だってニュークリアス何でしたっけ？核
核の重さが違うわ ぐるぐる回っているエネルギーのあれが
エレクトロンの方が違うわ
だからこれが炭素で これが水素と酸素というでしょうね
でも酸素は酸素の色を持っている
と 炭素は炭素の色を持っている
あるのは原子 普通化学で言ったっても
プロトンでできている核と
もうエレクトロンなんでしたっけ
電子 電子だけなんで 電子はどちらでも同じですよ
全く変わらない 酸素の電子も炭素の電子も同じものなんです
それで 過去の中にあるものもまた同じものなんです
過去の中にあるプロトンやらあれやらいろいろといっぱいありますけどね
むちゃくちゃたくさん入ってますけど
同じものなんです 同じものなんですけど
数が違うだけ 例えばウランとかはもう核の中でもういっぱい溜め込んじゃって
危ない危ない もうすぐ出すんですね
もう持てなくなっちゃって
だから欲張ったらとんでもないことになるんです
もう物質の中でものすごい欲張ってるんですよ
ウラニウムやらプルトニウムやら
ものすごい迷惑 だってそちらから出すものが
こちらの我々 我々の体の中の核の中に入り込んじゃうんですね
こちらはほんのちょっとしか核の中で品物を持ってないんだから
隙間があるんですよ 入り込んじゃう
入り込んじゃう時点で物がもう変わってるんです
だから放射能汚染しちゃうと癌になったり
もう全部変わってしまって死んじゃいますよね
欲張ったらあかんですよ
もうもうウラン考えたっても
どれほど危ないかとわかるでしょうに
人間の場合でもいっぱい金持ってるとかね
体中宝石ダイヤつけてぶらぶら歩いていっちゃうと
もう命までなくなっちゃうでしょうね
ない人は取ろうとするんです
だからそれは物質の世界でもある方程式なんです
欠けているものは何か他人から奪っちゃう
特に元素の中で一番機能するのは酸素でしょ
全然落ち着きないんですね
酸素っていうのは だから物は燃えるのは酸素のせいでしょ
それでもう食べ物とかね
酸素のせいで簡単に腐敗もうするでしょ
我々も酸素のせいで年取っちゃうんですよ
活性酸素なんかはもうものすごい危ないでしょうし
なんで酸素はあれほど落ち着きないんでしょうかね
あれ 泥棒なんですよ 酸素は
人間でいえばまあスリですね
他人から奪うんですよ
自分に欠けている あの
何でしたっけ？電子を
まあけしからんでね 人間の中でも盗む人やらね
まあスリとかえらい迷惑でしょうに
いっぱい盗人が住んでるんだったら
なかなかもう穏やかな気分でいられないんです
家に戻ってくるといろんなものがなくなっていて大変です
人間の心にもそういう働きがありますが
まあ物質の世界でも盗人もいるし
欲張ってはた迷惑する物質もいるし
それでまあ色の話なんですけど
結局は小さいカーフでできてるんですけど
書くものは自分の色を持っている
次に香りというものを持っている
それから味というものを持っている
なんで香りと味を入れたんでしょうかというと
これは人間の認識 人間を主体にして研究すると
大事なものなんです それからジオというものがあるんで
これがわからないんですね
これ今日勉強してください
この小さいカーフでできているものに面白い機能があるんですよ
他のものに入り込むことはできるんです
入り込んじゃうと そのものが変わるんですよ
例えば我々はもうニワトリを食べる
ニワトリの肉には体に入り込む入り込む
ことができるんですよ
だから食べたら元気になるんです
ニワトリっていうのは小さいカーフなんです
で 石も小さいカーフなんです
そこでニワトリという小さいカーフを食べたら元気になるんだけど
石という小さいカーフを食べると病気になっちゃう
石飲み込んじゃうとね
なんででしょうかね 石の小さいカーフが胃の中で大腸
小腸の中で入り込まないんです
この入り込む機能にジオ層と呼ぶんです
だから人間はご飯は食べられます
もう鶏も食べられます
しかし もう木とかは食べられませんね
葉っぱなんかはね まあ野菜と言いながら食べられますけど
草も食べられませんね
草なんか食べちゃうと
まあ植物だから病気になることはないんだけど
それで元気になるってことでもない
もう下痢になって体から出しちゃうんです
受け入れません なんで食物繊維をたくさん食べなさいって言うんでしょうかね
食物繊維の小さいカーフは体には吸収しないんです
だからお腹を洗ってくれると
またその中で体に 良い細菌やらね
その中で住みかにして育てるという考え方もある
だから食物繊維も食べましょうと
あれは栄養にも全然なりませんよ
そういうことで どんな品物にも他のものに入り込める
ことができるんです 牛は草食べれますよね
人間はちょっとダメなんですけど
需要の方はその受け取る側との関係で
だからあの 書いた文字があって
それはもう普通拭いても
例えばこのマジックインクでこの白板に書けば
拭いても拭いても消えないでしょうに
しかし ちょっと油で拭いちゃうとすぐ消えちゃうんです
マジックインクはもう治水家風なんですけど
普通のあれでは溶けないんです
そんなことで ある ある人にはある品物は溶けますよ
でもある品物は溶けないんです
まあわかりやすく言えば
体に鉄分が必要でしょうね
じゃあ鉄食べてみたら？入りませんよ
みんな馬鹿げたことに金粉も金箔も食べる人っているでしょうね
あれ食べたんだけど 体金色になるわけじゃないんです
ただ便所で流すだけ 全くも何の影響もないんです
全くもゼロ 溶けない で
いろいろ生命がいろいろ生き方してますよ
例えば海底火山がありますね
すっごい熱い そちらにものすごい毒ガス出ているんですよ
しかし そこら辺にも生命がいる
特別な生命 かなりでっかいですよ
なんか植物のように見えますけど
植物じゃないんです よくよく見たら
海底火山から出てくるガスを猛毒なのに
それで生きてるんです
そこでその植物が自分の治水家風作ったでしょ
それ食べる連中がいるんですよ
そちらには毒ですよ あの硫化水素はなんか毒ですから
食べ近づかない そこでどんどんどんどん生命が大きくなって
大きな外へ外へ増えていくと食べるんです
食べたらそちらの治水家風
体が作られる そうするとそちらを食べる別な動物がいて
どんどんどんどん上まで来ると我々も食べられます
上にいる魚とかは そういうふうなサイクルになっているのです
そこで物質は治水家風が他の治水家風に入り込むことができない場合は
もう存在が成り立たないんですね
そこで見てみると 宇宙の中を見てみても
もうギューッと合成して新しい星が現れたりする
今も太陽で起きてるのはそういうことなんです
水素が水素の中に入る込む
水素 水素は小さいカーフなんですよ
もう一つの水素も同じ小さいカーフなんですね
同じものは強引に入り込むんです
それですっごいエネルギーが出てくるんです
出るエネルギーも結局は小さいカーフなんです
ですから この滋養っていうのは面白い現象というか
必ずあります ないものはないんです
毒とかは 結局毒っていうのは体の中に入り込んで
入り込むから毒として働いてしまうわけです
そうそう それも滋養です
骨の中にカルシウムの代わりにカリウムが入るから骨が折れやすくなるというふうになるんでしょうけども
それに対して毒なんか滋養の機能なのに
どうしてそういう滋養っていうふうな
それはこの漢字 この言葉を使った人に聞いてください
あのパーリ語であるのは王者という
王者っていうのは流れるという意味なんです
滋養と使ったのは一般的な俗
俗的なレベルで 一般的なレベルでわかりやすくするために
なんでご飯食べたら元気になるのかというと
ご飯に王者があるんだからっていうことで
滋養があるんだからという風に言えば
もう誰にでもわかりやすい
だから徹底的な心理を語るんだからといって
一部の人々にだけわかるように語るわけじゃないんだ
みんなにわかるように語るために
そういう単語を使うことになったんです
だから アーハーラという言葉も使います
アーハーラという単語を日本語にして滋養にしているんです
しかし アーハーラというのは滋養という意味じゃないんです
それでもアーハーラというのは受け入れるという意味なんです
こちら側側から見ると
アーハーラ私が受け入れる
中に入れてもらう そちらから側を見ると王者なんです
入り込む だから同じものに立場がいる立場から言葉を 2つ使うんです
皆様方はアーハーラ食べ物滋養を食べているんです
自分の立場から 食べ物から見れば
食べ物に王者があるんだから
こいつの体に入り込んでやるぞと入り込んでいるんです
効果 効果 効果  効果  体内には効果がある
効果  うん でもその言葉を使えないです
それは使えない 効果って結果って意味になっちゃいますからね
やっぱり まあ王者ということ
言葉からまあないと思いますけど
流れるっていうこと意味なんですね
言葉を2つ 王者というか
アーハーラというか アーハーラっていうのは受け取る
受け取るという立場から
王者っていうのは流れ込むという
だから私はご飯食べる場合は
ご飯は私 私がアーハーラというんです
ご飯には王者があるんだから
体に入るんです そこで物事は変化する
増えたり減ったりする
入り込んだものは減る
別なものになる 食べたご飯は一部は体取っちゃいますから
一部の小さいカーフは
それから体から出す 小さいカーフはもう食べられませんね
しかしそちらにもまた小さいカーフだから
別な生命はそれは食べ物にする
それが物質の中でも起こるんです
だから物質を合成したり
いろいろできます 錬金術も論理的には可能です
その 4つは現れます そこで色
Varna それ説明しなかったっけ？色っていうのは色ですから
色っていうのはこのスペクトラムとかね
いろいろ光で見るもので
そこでどんな物質も自分に光という小さいカーフが当てると
何を吸収して何を出すのかと
自分の特色あるんです
それで色っていうのは成り立つんですよ
面白いことっていうのは
光が当たるっていうことは
光が当たったものは変化するんですよ
誰も気にしていないんです
光が 例えば このスクリーンに光が当たると
一部を吸収して一部を反射するんですね
反射する分は我々に見える
吸収したものは地水火風でしょ
だから変わってるんです
だから光にも当たるもんじゃないんですよ
すぐたちまちもう体が変わるんです
そこで放射線やらレントゲンやら全て光の一種ですよ
赤外線とかね それからアルトラバイオレットは紫外線とかね
なぜ紫外線が危ないんですかね
全部吸収するんです 出してくれない
我々の地水火風の体が
我々の地水地水火風の体に紫外線が当たると
紫外線が全部丸ごと受け取る
返せません これです ものすごい体に変化が起こるんです
細胞はたちまち壊れていくんです
レントゲンも同じです
すごい体に悪いんです
放射線も光の一種ですけど
あらゆる放射線 いろんなたくさんありますけどね
体に入ると まあ吸収しちゃう
吸収する分ではもう細胞は質が変わって壊れているんです
そういうところが普通の光に当たっても
我々の体は変化する 別なものになる
まあどうすることもできんよ
では暗闇でいたらどうでしょうかと
暗闇にいたってもありますけど
はい まあ一応この 4つも覚えておく
そうすると 8になります
はい 次 で まあだから私は勝手に
これどうやって読めばいいんですか
正直ですか 正直と書いたんですけど
そんな漢字はないんですけど
いわゆるよって生まれる
本来あるものじゃないんです
よって生まれる物質 これ副産物なんですよ
パーリ語でウパーダールーパと言ってるんですね
また 20種ですよ 上 4つ説明しました
また 20あります 副産物
それで物質はすべて 28種です
基本的には地水火風だけで全部説明つくんですが
やっぱり合わせて ちょっとちょっと違うという
例えば基本的には黄色い色があって
青い色があるでしょうに
合わせちゃうと なんだもう緑になるんじゃないんですかね
そうすると世の中で緑色っていうものは存在するんです
だから合わせちゃうと何か別なものになるという
例えば酸素と水素を合わせちゃうと
なんだ水になるでしょうに
しかし 水になってもあるのは酸素と水素なんです
これが面白いと 複産物
だから水っていうのは複産物なんです
水と水素酸素は全く違う
別々にいると 水素酸素が一緒になっちゃうと水になる
水になると 水は別なものとして見える
機能もする だから複産時期も色もまあ考えるべき問題なんです
まあはい 次に行きます
そこで私たちに関係あるもの
体の五感が機能する物質は
感じる外の物質も一つつに分けて理解する
これはパーサで六と五と六
まあもう私にも読んでいる文章は読めない
わからないんですけどね
そこであの これなんです
我々の五感があるんですよ
五感があってもただの地水火風なんですよ
五感というのは目耳鼻と舌と体の感覚なんですね
その五感で物事を知ってるでしょ？目で見えてるでしょうに
何で見えるんですかね
目で なんで鼻で見えないんですかね
なぜ耳で見えないんですかね
やはり目には見えるという機能があるんです
その物質は何なのかと
仏教は物質で見るんです
やっぱり目の物質は この光に反応する感受性を持ってるんです
同じ地水火風なのに 光に反応する
耳も同じ細胞でできてるんですけど
音に反応する だからその音に反応する
光に反応する 硬いものに反応するとかね
香りに反応する そういうことで五感がありまして
そちらもあの複産色として一つ
まあただ余計にカテゴライズする余計じゃなく
それはどうしても必要なんです
それで目に入る色は別に
またルーパって その時もルーパっていう言葉を使いますからね
まだ目に入るもの いわゆる目で認識できる対象
耳で認識できる音 舌で認識できる香りじゃなくて
味 鼻で認識できる香り
体で認識できる硬さと温度
そこはまた一つ例えば対象は一つ
体にも一つあると 窓口はそこで考えちゃうんだからね
そういうのは複産物 例えば目の地水火風が少々でも変わっちゃうと見えなくなっちゃうんです
例えば目の中でなんか透明な液体あるでしょ？水晶体とかなんとかっていう
それにもうちょっと何か入れちゃうとどうなるんですかね
見えない 大体年取ってくると濁っちゃうでしょ
で タンパク質は分解しても体から出ていかない状態になっちゃうんです
それで白くなっちゃうんです
それで白内障という病気でも取り出さないといけなくなっちゃうんですね
だから地水火風 ちょっと変わっただけで副産物も変わってしまう
だから黄色い色と青い色を混ぜたら緑になるんだけど
こんなちょっと別な色で入れちゃうと緑が変わってしまう
例えば赤色でもちょっと繋げちゃうと
もう大変なことになるんです
緑でなくなっちゃうんです
それが複産物なんですね
例えば色の場合は何万色もあると言ってるでしょうに
コンピューターでなんかを見てみると
もう何万色もできるぞとか
あんなのは嘘で 目に見えるのは 3つの色しか見えないし
しかしその 3つの色はあらゆる割り当てで組み合わせて何万色というんです
本当に見えますよ 緑色も見えるし
茶色も見えるし 灰色も見えるし
いろんな色も見える でもその色は副産物です
それでこちらで色は 10種類ありますということで
はい 次 はい それで物質のことは終わり
まだ 28種類ありますけど
全部説明できません 例えば我々の体
男の体か女の体かとしているのも副産物なんです
小さいカフが集めたら副産物として
まあ例えば黄色いと青い色を集めたら緑になるような感じで
別な物質もあるように見える
それは 2つありまして
あれはもう一対ルーパプリサルーパというんですね
生命の体は男か女に オスかメスかに分けるんです
そこで仏教から言えば
細胞一個一個オスはオスなんです
髪の毛も何だかんでも
ただの生殖器官を見て調べて
我々動物はオスかメスか調べるでしょうに
そういうふうに調べる必要はないんです
我々にはあるんだけど
細胞一個一個も男性か女性かとも決まってるんです
それも一つの物質として仏教で説明するんです
はい まあそれで それから 2番目に
2番目の塊に行きます
あ 銃ですね 銃といっても感受性なのです
感じることです そこで小さいカフがなんてことなく感じるんですよ
もう物質ではありません
物質は終わりました 体のことは終わりました
それだけで私は全部じゃないんだからね
感じるんでしょ それにも感じるってことはすごいことです
手で感じるは足で感じるは
お腹で感じるは もういろんなところで耳で鼻で
だから感じるということは別な塊に
カテゴリに山にしています
はい 次 五感と心っていうのはいいですね
という 6つのところで
外の世界と内の世界を感じる
そこで五感というのは目一つでしょ
目であれがあるんだ これであるんだと外の世界を感じる
耳ででも外の音を感じる
だから外の世界あるんだそうと知ってるんです
体でも外の世界を感じる
だから机あるんだそう
触ったらわかるんだよと言うんです
そこで鼻で香りを感じる
香りを感じて 花が咲いてるんだそうと庭にはと言うんです
別に見たこともないのに
それで庭に花が咲いてるんだということは鼻で感じるんですね
花咲いてるんだというのは頭の妄想がいるんですけど
花で実際に 香りだけは感じているんです
これは味で 舌で感じる
体で感じる それから音といったっても
時々我々は外の音じゃなくて
体の中の音も聞こえる時がありますよ
よく聞こえるのはお腹の音とかはよく聞こえますけど
また微妙に血液流れる音やら心臓の鼓動やら聞こえる時はあります
そんなの聞こえちゃうとすごいうるさいんだからね
一応無視するということをするんです
だから無視するんだから
体の音はないようにと勘違いしています
体もものすごいうるさいんです
しかし それを聞きちゃうともうたまったもんじゃないんだから
我々はこの意識しない
体内の音に体外の音を意識する
そう感じること それがヴェーダナーと言うんです
はい 感じるといえば一つの機能ですが
苦 楽 苦 不苦不楽と 3つにすることもできる
まあ感じるんだってじゃ
ただの感じるだけ  1個なんですよ
しかし 手を触ってみたら
楽しい感覚や苦しい 痛いと
あるいは普通やというふうに言えます
そういうことで 感覚は 3つに分けられます
はい 六感にすると 60 になる
例えば五感と意をまとめると六感なんです
だから六感で 6種類の感情感覚が生まれるということで 6つになります
それを上の 3つに分けてみると
18種のヴェーダナーが生まれます
だからそれはどう取ってもいいよとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
ヴェーダナーが 1個だよと理解しているんだらどうそうと
いやいや  3つだよ どうそう
どうそうと 別にどうったことはない 2
つだよと 苦と楽だけやと言ったら
それでもどうそうと その都度その都度分析するだけで
そこでこの 18 はまた分ける時もあります
過去現在未来に分けちゃうと
18 3つでかけてみなぶっちゃいけないんです
それから 内の中を感じることを外の中感じることには
全部ただ2つで分けられます
かけます そうすると全部 108 が出ているんです
そんなのはただの好き勝手な分析で
そんなに厳密なものではないんです
なんで 108 種類があると言うんでしょうかというと
やっぱり煩悩は八八か象で生まれますよと
過去についても煩悩が生まれる
もうとっくにないのに
将来についても煩悩が生まれる
全然存在していないのに
それ言いたくて 108 にしているんです
108 の計算は簡単です
3つかける  6 かける  3つかける 2
これが感じるという世界です
本当にシンプルでバカバカらしいんですよ
ただ指で手をこうやって触ると感じるだけの話なんですよ
これで幸せや不幸や痛いやあれやこれやと言ってケンカするは欲張るはもう無茶苦茶なんです
ただそれだけのことは
耳で音が感じる それであらゆることを妄想したりして
大変です はい 銃といっても感受性なのです
感じることです ただ感じることです
はい これ戻ったって同じものですね
うん ヴェーダナーが生き物に必ず起こる
我々生き物やというのはヴェーダナーがあるんだからなんです
だからこのカップは生き物じゃないんです
カップは小さい花粉なんですが
感じないんですよ 私も小さい小さい花粉なんですけど
感じるんですね だから私は生き物で
カップは生き物ではありません
はい それが私がいるという実感になってしまう
だから私がいると思っちゃうんですね
感じるんだからしょうがないでしょうに
はい したがって実体がない
ということの心理ができす
理解できす 実体がないことの理解できず
生きることに執着して苦しむ
もう感じたってもすぐもうどうったことないんだぞとわからない
私がいるんじゃないかと
私がいるんだったら 私にいろんなものが必要でしょうし
敵を倒さなくちゃいけないし
良い感覚を作れるものいっぱいいっぱいもらわなくちゃいかんし
ということで執着して
あらゆる苦しみが生まれるんですね
このヴェーダナーのせいで
はい 欲 怒りなどの汚れ
煩悩が感情によって現れる
だからこの感じることから欲が生まれますよ
感じることから怒りが生まれますよ
人が何か言う 耳で感じる
頭でそれは処理する それで頭でも感じる
あれ？私はぶち込ませてるんではないかと
それで怒る 感じなきゃ何もないのに
ということなんです はい
感情がそれに変化して消えていく
一定不変に争うと それを理解してほしい
ものすごい喧嘩しなきゃ感受性がないんですよ
音 音楽を聴いてるといえば
強烈に音が変わってるんですよ
それと同時に耳の中で感受性も強烈に変わっていくんですよ
それが音楽を聴いているという現象になるんです
でなきゃ聞こえませんよ
で 触ると感じがあるわ
座ると別な感じがあるわ
例えば座っている時の感覚が立つとないでしょうに
だったらもう変わるのは当たり前でしょうに
痛い痛いと思ったって瞬時に消えるでしょうに
永遠不滅じゃないんです
なのに我々はそれを認めないんですよ
なんででしょうかね それで私がいる
私がいる 私がいると 実際にいるんじゃないか
感じているんではないかと
その感じているものはずっと変化しているのに
私に子供がいるんじゃないかな
楽しいなと思っていて
子供はなんかわがまま言っちゃうとまた怒ったりする
子供は電話一本もかけないと寂しいなと思ったりもする
それで我々の感覚がすぐすぐ変わるんですよ
子供がいるんだというデータにすぎても
あなたはそうすると幸福を感じているかというと
とんでもないんです 子供がいて幸せだというのは無知な人の考え方なんです
子供がいて幸せということじゃなくて
瞬間瞬間 あらゆる感じを感じるんです
それで忘れっぽいだから楽しい感じだけ覚えておく
だから子供がいて幸せやと
そうじゃないんだよ 子供がいると時々楽しいし
時々疲れて疲れてもうもうヘタヘタになるし
もう時々もうものすごく嫌にもなるし
すごく悩んだり苦しんだりもするし
例えば子供がもうもうろくに勉強しない受験には
そうするとなんて幸せだと思いますかね
母親は うちの子はもう高校生で全然勉強しないんですけど
楽しい 楽しいと幸せやと思わないでしょうに
だからなんでこの全部まとめて言うんですかね
バカなこと 子供がいて楽しいと秒単位で言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
この秒で楽しい この秒で苦しい
この秒で死んでしまおうと思っていると
それが正しいんですよ
そうするとまとめたら結論が出てこないはずなんです
みんなもう簡単にもうもうもう掃除して結論出すんです
全部まとめて お金があると
ああ これは幸せやと 美味しいものを食べられると
ああ なんて幸せですかと
それって何の意味のないくだらない考え言葉なんです
俗世間である一切の考え方はそんなもんなんです
だから仏教では一つも受け入れないんです
無常を知る人はそんなことは言わない
すごい違う世界にいるんです
だから子供がいることを幸福やというならば
ずっと幸福でなければいけない
しかし そんなことはあり得ない
感じることに我々は幸福と言うんです
それである時は子供は楽しく感じる
ある時は苦しく感じる
これがずっと変化する
子供が犯罪を犯して警察に捕まれるというと
親が幸せいっぱいになるんですかね
なんて幸せでしょう うちの子が警察に捕まりましたと
麻薬所持して現行犯で逮捕されたと
楽しい 楽しいと 生きていてよかったと
神様感謝しますと言うんですかね
だからそうやって理解してほしい
感覚が常に変わるんだと
一定不変ではありませんと
一番やばいのは もう苦しみであろうが楽しみであると自分がスーッと感じ続けるんだから
故に我がありきと言うんです
これで解脱できなくなっちゃうんです
我がありきだったら 執着しなくちゃあかんだから
ずっと輪廻転生しなくちゃあかんだから
だからこの無知の象徴的人間はどれほど象徴的に無知であるかということは
非常に見せたのはデカルトなんです
西洋人の無知を固めてくれたんです
やっぱりみんな困っていた
魂があるとか何とか言ってるんだけど
わからへんので それでデカルトがあってお前考えてるでしょ？だって俺が考えてるんだから俺がいるでしょうにと
だからいると 本当にガキに見えるぐらいアホなことを言ってるんですよ
しかし そちらの方々にとってはものすごい哲学者なんです
仏教から見ればもうもう白鳥さんがもっとありがたいんですよ
そんなくだらんこと言わんだからね
すごい無知なんです このコギトエルゴスムというこの言葉から始まった西洋哲学は
はい それでサンニャーって何なのかと
3番目の塊 サンニャーとは
例えば見えたものは黄色いだ
四角いだなどのデータにすることです
で 体に情報が触れるでしょ
それをデータにするんです
耳に音が触れちゃうと
すぐデータにするんです
目で何か見るとすぐデータにするんです
認識というか概念するんですね
それがサンニャーということですね
そうと言うんですけどね
過去のサンニャー 今見る聞く触れるものの理解にも役に立つ
で 過去の何か花を見て
えっと 今使っている花なんて言いますか
はい アサガオ で 過去にそれを見たことがあれば
今日ちょっとそこら辺でアサガオ今はないんですけど
見たらアサガオだ すぐデータにするんです
だから過去のサンニャーも今のサンニャーに役に立つんです
はい 勉強する 経験するというのはサンニャーを増やすことです
いっぱいサンニャー溜ますんです
勉強したということを言うんです
はい 次 サンニャーとは概念の塊
体系だとも理解できる
これは概念の塊だと理解すれば
例えばポンと言えばわかるでしょ
意味はペットボトルと言えばすぐわかるでしょ
サンニャーです  だからずっとサンニャーできてるんですよ
サンニャーがなければここまで来られませんし
机を区別できないし 椅子も区別できないし
これ区別できなかったら
机に座って椅子に椅子椅子でものを書こうとメモしようと思ったら
もう成り立たんでしょうに
だからもう我々はもうサンニャーいっぱいやりまして
それで生きているんです
はい そうもサンニャーも常に変化して消えてゆく
一定不変に争う それで人間が勉強したもの
概念体系が自分だと勘違いするバカもいますよ
時々すごく勉強するとどんどん我が強くなるでしょうに
もう知識人というのはものすごいおっかないんですよ
人格が悪くて 人の話を聞かないわ
もうもう何か言ったらもう聞こうともしないで
そんなのはないよと すぐもう反対するわ
例えば数学の教授のところに小学生の子供が行って
おじいちゃん これちょっと教えてくれって言ったら
もうもう誰かに聞いてくださいとかね
すごくもう人格悪いんですよ
なぜかというと 俺がもう数学の教授がなんでもう３掛ける２は６やと子供に教えなくちゃあかんかと
という態度であれば 自分の概念がで自我私やと思っているんです
そのバカが知らないのは
誰か野球バットで頭ぶん殴っちゃうと全部忘れるということなんです
脳障害 脳腫瘍でも起きちゃうと
何の数学もひとかけらもなくなっちゃうんですよ
だって常に私たちはサンニャーサンニャー入れて入れて増やすんだけど
同時に減って減って減って減っていくんです
だから一定不変ではないんです
流れていくんです それも自我ではありません
はい 次 で 行ということ
サンカーラサンカールーパーダナカンドということ
これ４番目の塊 サンカーラとは
認識とともに現れる衝動ポテンシャルです
何か認識すると なんかイライラというか
なんかやりたくなっちゃうんですよ
そのエネルギーにサンカーラというんです
一切の行動を引き起こすんですね
感じたものについてどうするべきかと決める
見たい 触りたい 食べたいとかね
だから我々は行動しているんですよ
我々やっているすべての行動はこの行のせいなんです
サンカーラのせいです
歩いたり 座ったり 食べたり
喋ったり 考えたり 落ち込んだり
悩んだり 楽しがったり
もう何かやらずにいられないでしょ
一瞬たりとも何かをやらずにいられないんです
それが行ということで
サンカーラということで大変です
例えば人に瞑想する時でも
じっと体を動かさないで
微妙に動かさないでいろと言ったら
ものすごい苦しいんですよ
私はよく言いますけど
座った人は置物のように体を動かさずと
立った人は柱のように体を動かさずいてくださいと
いられませんね しかし
頑張ってみてください
たちまちサンカーラは見えてくるはずなんです
一人も発見してないんだけど
なんだこれと で 私は言う通りにやってないからなんです
文句を言うんです そんなこと言ったって苦しいでしょうと
だったら勝手にしろと
本人の考え方で瞑想修行できんだからね
瞑想はブッダの悟った人の考え方で言うんです
だからできるかできないか
そんな知ったことじゃないんです
言う通りにやるんです
柱のように十分ぐらい立っていようとすると
いかに体が動かそう動かそうと動いて動こうと思っているのかと
だから私はあえて足を広げて
この物理的なところは固定してもらう
だから倒れない状態にする
体重のせいやとかね 地球のせいやとか言わせないようにして
足をちょっと広げてこういうふうに立っている
手を結んでもらうんですよ
そうするとちゃんと足でバランスを整えていなくちゃいけないんです
これができるんだからね
柱のようにいることはできるんですよ
慣れてくると体が止まってもらえますよ
知恵が開発すると しかし
これ十分 十五分とかになってくると
もう動きたいんですよ
ものすごくもうあのエネルギーが
嫌なエネルギーが出てくる
それが行なんです 気持ちよく三十分で瞑想しようかなと思っても
まあもう二十分になってくると
もう三十分過ぎてるんではないかとかね
だからサンカーラがわからないわけじゃないよ
簡単にわかりますよ 何かしたがる
そこで瞑想 すごくうまくいっちゃうとしゃべりたくない
サンカーラがのエネルギーは減るんですよ
サンカーラが減っていってくると
午後だけになるとイライラなくなっちゃいますからね
大体瞑想を真面目にする人っていうのは
まあもうほとんどしゃべりたくないんです
面倒くさい それにしゃべると頭がまたガチャガチャガチャッと動くんだからね
やりたくない それでみんな私に瞑想の報告なんかしないでしょうし
しかし 瞑想終わったらしゃべるでしょ
みんなその声でわかるんです
やれやれと キャキャキーキーとね
もし自分がしゃべる しゃべらなくちゃいけないところはしゃべりますけど
それは聞かなくちゃいけない相手以外聞こえるとかなり重症です
子供と同じなんです 私がいるマンションでどこにいるかわからないです
子供がもう声出しちゃうと
もう建物中聞こえるんです
すごいサンカーラがもう働いてますからね
そういうことでサンカーラを理解してください
はい このポテンシャルはいつか結果を出すまで溜まるでしょ
何か見たら何かもういらだちが生まれるんです
何かしたいと それしなかったら溜まるんです
いつかやるんです 今世でできなかったら来世ででもやりますよ
だから輪廻するエネルギーもサンカーラなんです
消えません 結果出すまで消えませんと言ったっても収まりません
それも変化しますよ 例えば逆のサンカーラ使っちゃうと
前のサンカーラ消えちゃうし
例えば欲でもう苦しんでいる人にお布施などを奉仕するなどを推薦すると
あの嫌なエネルギーが消えちゃって
もっと穏やかなエネルギーになるんです
それもすごいサンカーラなんです
しかし 穏やかですけど
欲の場合は奪わなくちゃあかんだけど
お布施の気持ちになってくると
奪わなくてもついてくるという状態になる
その時点では楽なんです
百万強引に儲かるよりは
百万回回ってくるのは楽でしょう
その場合は自然に過ぎ去るものだから
まあ別にという気持ちでもいられます
苦労して頑張って儲かったならば
そうはならない 絶対これは誰にもあげるもんかとものすごく執着しちゃう
だからこの善行為もサンカーラであるし
悪行為もサンカーラなんです
で 悪行為 人は殴ったらその人は殴り返さなくても殴り返されるエネルギーは溜まっちゃったんです
これいつか結果出す 出して欲しくなければ
逆のエネルギーでそれは機能しないようにするということになるんです
でも誰もそんなことやらんでしょ
ただ溜まるだけでしょ
エネルギーは 西洋の言葉でストレスというのはそれなんです
ストレスというのは怒りですね
怒りが溜まるとストレスというんです
はい 怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬 欲
高慢などの感情もサンカーラの中にぞくぞく
まあすべてこの煩悩やら何やら
もう善行為も悪行為も全部サンカーラということの中に入り込む
もう入れ込んじゃうんです
しかし サンカーラの本来の意味は
ただ何かしたいという意欲
それだけなんですけど
意欲そのものだけなんですけど
もう他のたくさん心理学的なものあります
全部まとめて一つにするんです
はい それで終わりです
行が常に変化して消えていく
それも一定不変にはならない
食べたいと思っても 一生食べたいと気持ちでいるわけじゃないでしょうに
何か食べたらまあいいや
飲みたいと それを飲んだところで
一生飲みたい気分でいるわけじゃないでしょうに
すぐすぐ消える そういうことだから
サンカーラも私ではあらずと
私の魂でもないと決めなくちゃいけない
それで最後にいきます
ヴィンヤーナ 識 認識ですね
ヴィンヤーナとは認識する働き機能です
それちょっとわからないという人々もいますけど
何でしょうかね とにかくまあ耳に音が触れると
もう聞くというヴィンヤーナが働くんですね
だからヴィンヤーナっていうのは音だと認識する
で 色だと認識するとか
ただ認識することなんですね
絶えず何かを認識し続ける機能は識という
で 私たちにはもう瞬間たりとも認識しないでいられないんです
いつでも何かを認識しているんですよ
はい 考えることがなければ妄想でもする
大事なことを考えたりする
それもなくなっちゃうと
もう頭をずっと妄想で続けられちゃうんです
止まることできんです
はい それもなければ 自分という実感だけでもやり続ける
例えば 考えることもなくなっちゃったとしても
自分がいるんじゃないかなと
体を感じるんですよ 日本では一度も経験ないんですけど
ヴィパッサナー瞑想もしっかりと強烈にやると
妄想がもう潰せますから
妄想が潰されて出てこなくなるんです
あんまりにももうやられてやられてコテンパンにやられちゃうと
それでもでは悟ったかと
じゃないんです 悟りの経験を出すために
ではあなたは体を認識しなさいと言うんです
体あるってことを知っているんだから
やっぱり認識しているんです
はい あ 思考力のない生命を読み上げ
思考力のない生命にも自分という実感だけはある
だから動物も輪廻転生しますよ
どんな生命でも 生命に脳細胞ないんだから
何も考えられないでしょう
だったら怒り 憎しみ 何もないでしょうとかね
と言っても かわいそうで
生命にも自分がいるという実感がありますよ
それすごいエネルギーなんです
認識です そうすると行が生まれるんです
認識するたびにヴィンヤーナ
識が変わる 識が変わることこそが認識というものです
なんかわからないようになっていますけど
で ヴィンヤーナっていうのは別にあるんじゃないんです
何か認識することにヴィンヤーナと言うんです
だから黒板だと言ったところで
それヴィンヤーナなんです
黒板を認識 黒板として認識したんです
目に入ったのは別なデータなんですけど
頭は黒板ということで認識しちゃったんです
それがヴィンヤーナというんです
それがずっと続けているんです
あらゆるものを認識しながら
だから一つ一つの認識が終わっちゃうと
次 次のものを認識するんです
その機能にヴィンヤーナというんです
はい 色が常に変化して消えていく
言って笛にならす 色も変わるでしょうに
このスクリーンを見る時
別な色 黒板を見ると別な色
自分のノートを見るとまた別な
目で見てもそうやって変わるんです
すごい速さで はい これで 5つは終わりました
ではまとめます この 5つは離れません
今 5つでできています
体が全然離れません 肉体に心がビッタリついてるんです
まあわかりやすい でも例えばオレンジジュースというと
オレンジと水が離れることはできないでしょうに
一緒にやるでしょう そんな感じで
これがオレンジで これが水やとは言えません
離れることはできない
互いに一緒に組み合わせて続く
お互いに組み合わせて機能しています
はい 色も なんか間違ってる
あ 色も性質も違う  ５本の小川が１本になって大河に大河として流れるようなものです
私の命っていうのは 色違う
小川 色も水も違う 小川が５つが来て一つになる
今私はそれなんです だからそれ分解していないんだから
みんな人を神様に創られたとか
神様が動物と違って人間に魂霊魂をつけてくれたとかね
あんなのは何の意味もないんですよ
なぜかというと 自分たちで考えてるでしょうに
だから実感が強いだけの話で
動物は殺して食いたいんだから
動物の魂がないというだけの
何の根拠もなく よくそういうことをもう昔のおかしい人々は言い続けたんです
何も研究はない 何も修行はない
なのによく信じる  21世紀になっているにも関わらず
はい 高等の瞑想によって心を体から離すことはできるが
そのエネルギーが消えると
また心が物質に体に依存する
体と心を離すことっていうのは
もう相当無理 一緒よ そこでものすごいこのある瞑想がありまして
普通の 瞑想を進んで進んで進んで
すごく進んでいったところで
レベルすごい高いところになったところで
体から心が離れますけど
その強烈な心のエネルギーがある時だけなんです
で わかりやすく言えば
例えば糸に何か石とかなんとかつなげておくとぶら下がっているんですよ
それに糸にエネルギーを与えるんです
回すんです 回すと手からエネルギーが入るんです
そうすると 石がずっと立ってるんです
エネルギーなくなっちゃうと
ボーンとまた落ちるんです
で 糸と石の例えで その場合でも石には糸がつなげてますけど
遠心分離なんとかするのは同じ法則なんです
回しちゃうと 各部品が本当は一緒なのに分かれてしまうんです
すごいエネルギー与えなくちゃいけないんです
それで心にもすごいエネルギーを与えると
体から一時的には離れる
そのエネルギーで死んでしまえば
もう体がなしに生まれるんです
心だけで その時はもうかなり長い時間いられますけど
で エネルギーが減ったらまた輪廻転生します
はい それで五のまとめ
色といったのは物質ですね
物質っていうのは体 この受想行識と言ったのは心
精神というもの それで自分というものを二つに分けて考えることができるんです
はい 今日は終わり で そういうことで
お釈迦様が微妙に我々の存在を分析して
何一つも止まらないというか
止まらない 一定していない
一時的なものであって
まあシャボン玉のようなものであると
蜃気楼のようなものであると
執着するには値しないと
それ分かれば 今の苦しみっていうのは全部消えて
体が自由になるんだという話です
はい 話は終了です どうもありがとうございます